[Music]
hydrogen reacts with oxygen to form
water and we saw the reason why this
chemical equation is unbalanced the
number of oxygen atoms on the left is
not equal to the number of oxygen atoms
on the right the important question is
can be balanced this equation the answer
is yes let's go step by step and see how
we can balance it as the first step it's
always a good idea to draw boxes around
each element or compound like this why
did we draw these boxes it's because
nothing inside the boxes can be changed
or altered when we are balancing the
equation you'll understand better soon
next we form a table like we've already
drawn here
this row in the table tells us that the
number of atoms of oxygen on the
reactant side is not equal to that on
the product side it's due on the left
and one on the right so let's try
balancing the oxygen atoms first
as does one oxygen atom on the right and
two on the left we multiply h2o with two
what we have here is a partially
balanced equation the number of oxygen
atoms on the right is 2 and there on the
left is also 2 also remember that you
cannot alter the formulae of compounds
or elements involved in the reaction
which means that to balance the oxygen
atoms we cannot change h2o and write it
as H 2 O 2 this would be incorrect let's
go back to the partially balanced
equation the number of oxygen atoms on
each side is balanced now but what about
hydrogen when we multiplied this
compound with 2
what happened the number of oxygen atoms
were equal on each side but what about
hydrogen atoms
the number of hydrogen atoms on the
right became four and what's the number
of hydrogen atoms on the left
it's two so how do you think we can
balance the hydrogen atoms now
we can multiply the hydrogen on the
left-hand side with two to get this is
the equation balance now absolutely we
can form the table and verify it this is
what you'll get so we simply multiply
the appropriate elements or compounds as
necessary to balance each and every
element when all elements are balanced
we say that the chemical equation is
balanced easy wasn't it why don't you
try balancing this chemical equation
you'll see the solution in the next part
of the lesson
[Music]